[Music]
a mummy and
so we're in Singapore Airlines right now
about the tank to Sydney it's almost a
3:00 a.m. in the morning so both mom and
I were really tired but we're really
excited because this is going to be in
one week of an adventure travel so we'll
be visiting lots of different places and
be sure to watch at least get through
the next trip week a month every year
out let a mother and daughter trip and
this year it's Sydney we took a flight
from Kuala Lumpur and had a shot transit
in Singapore welcome to Sydney
[Music]
we're finally here at the bridge climb
I've been looking forward to do this
crime apparently is gonna take about one
and a half up to three hours so let's
get in and get on some printer
this was a vivid climb which was only
available during Vivid Sydney so I just
heard that it's going to be a it so long
preparation takes 40 minutes oh it's
just fine I'm really excited about this
so let's head up and stop so we weren't
allowed to bring our own phones or
camera but what a view
so we just finished the bridge climb it
was absolutely freezing out there I
can't even speak properly right now the
wind was so strong but the view of the
entire city city was so beautiful wasn't
it and we even managed to dance yeah
enjoy every bit of it and I was so fun
look at this we are officially certified
our next stop was spot Stephens where we
did quadbiking hello we are going one by
day
I'm fully so adventurous right now got
my helmet on and let's do this
[Music]
no this is not a desert we were riding
across the largest moving sand dune in
the southern hemisphere and just look at
that sunset just about 30 minutes away
is the adventure camel rights ah just
look at them
say hello to Syd nan average a camel can
live up to 45 years
Syd is only 27 years old that's just two
years younger than I am this ripe is
suitable for all ages and it is a great
way to experience the sand dunes and
Beach with your family
[Music]
we traveled about 100 kilometres to hunt
the valley good morning so mom and I got
up at 4 a.m. this morning just to get
ready for hot-air balloon mum money
the pilot determines the launch side
depending on the wind direction in the
morning this was a very hands-on
activity so we had to work together as a
team to inflate the hot-air balloon
which took about 20 minutes
[Music]
the fire took us by surprise
at first but we got used to it
[Music]
we were about 2,000 feet above the hunt
of value wine regions and the views were
spectacular
[Music]
time to rip up it took the entire team
to pack up the balloon all 20 of us
everybody helped even the little kid
[Music]
believe me it wasn't light well that was
my morning workout done it was a long
drive back down to the Blue Mountains it
took about four hours and over 300
kilometers mum and I did a bush walking
tour with Tim who has been hiking in the
Blue Mountains for the past 50 years tim
is very knowledgeable and he explained
about the different habitats living
there this is another eucalyptus called
eucalyptus peppery turn
so this is a peppermint smells it made
the hike is so much more interesting
[Music]
there are lots of different hiking spots
in New South Wales and the views are
just breathtaking you can either choose
to hike on your own or get a guide to
show you around like how we did this is
my kind of travel get outdoors do
something active and you will enjoy your
surrounding and the environment so much
more we're just about at the end of our
trip right now heading back to Sydney
I've spent four amazing days with you've
been so amazing it's it's been a really
nice trip because it has been really
informative as well so basically we
traveled from Sydney to pod Stevens to
Hunter Valley and then to the Blue
Mountains and now we're making our way
around back to city city again so as you
mentioned it's a really good loop for
someone who wants to do this trip in
everydays so we're just in Darling
Harbour right now strolling along and
checking out Vivid Sydney look at the
view how can I leave this city without
experiencing vivid Sydney which was the
main reason for my trip there is Sydney
only happens once a year over the winter
season and this is actually its 11th
year the lights turn on from 5:30 p.m.
onwards across different areas in Sydney
and this brings the entire city to life
especially in the cool weather besides
that you can also participate in the
vivid idea talks happening in different
locations Vivid Sydney is something to
look forward to when visiting during the
period of late May to mid-june and when
I'm traveling I love to explore the
healthy food scene Sydney has so much to
offer from delicious find
vegan food - super fresh local seafood
lots of cafes serving wholesome and
healthy foods and the list just goes on
and on and on now it's time to say
goodbye to this wonderful city another
unforgettable mother and daughter
adventure